So here is a good picture of how
virtualization is related to
security and isolation and
things like that.
This is your physical hardware.
On top of that, we have this hypervisor.
It's also called a virtual
machine monitor, or VMM.
And on top of that,
we have this different VM.
So, this is VM1.
This is VM2.
This is VMn let's say if
you have one of n of those.
If you somehow compromised
this operating system,
it only effects the user
applications we have here.
It does nothing to the user
applications we have running
in other virtual machines.
This is what we're saying,
is your trusted computing base.
As long as you can trust this,
the isolation across virtual
machines is going to work.
So, compromise of this operating system
is not going to affect these other
virtual machines and
the applications running in those.
For us, virtualization is important
because our focus is in security and
you see this isolation
of these applications.
Earlier they all shared
the same operating system.
Now they only share a Hypervisor.
Why might that give you better security?
We're going to talk about that next.